whether there is any like valuable
Consciousness that doesn't really matter
too much to me so you think if it feels
excruciating pain as like a newborn baby
that doesn't matter no I don't
know
I sound like a sociopath
a pain is a very little consequence to
me as soon as when you're dead you won't
feel it I mean they used to think that
newborn babies don't feel pain so they
used to do surgery on newborn babies
because they said to these newborn
babies can't feel pain they're not
sufficiently conscious they're not
sufficiently self-aware and so they
would just do surgery on newborn babies
without any pain pills without any
anesthesia but they changed that a few
decades ago because there was a pretty
unanimous consensus within medical
science that newborn babies can feel
pain even if they can't pass the mirror
test